il convenait de ces bandes en libre
service qu'on trouve dans tous les
magasins de cette célèbre chaîne de
fast-food alors la fign avaient lieu au
moment de finaliser la commande sur le
service click and collect qui vous
permet ensuite d'aller récupérer votre
commande au guichet il fallait
absolument choisir le menu golden menu
et vous pouviez ensuite bien choisir à
l'infini d'autres menus et pour
seulement 0 euros ou presque cet
internaute par exemple a acheté quatre
menus pour un euro 80 centimes pour cet
internaute certains vous allez le voir
sont même pris des caddies la chaîne
s'est exprimée a réagi
la situation est en phase de
normalisation on avait notre spécial
justice ont inscrit nos spécialistes
gastronomie et l'histoire et ensuite
j'ai appris après cette histoire que
mcdonald's voulait se faire rembourser
par les gens qui les avaient volé qui
avait payé par carte bleue exactement
c'est dire qu'ils allaient quand même
être avoir un retrait sur leur compte de
tout ce qu'ils avaient commandés et
c'est en liquide à temps qu'il faut tant
pis pour mcdonald's mais du coup je me
dis enfin c'est pas très juste parce que
là il se trouve maintenant il sait ce
qu'on ne dit pas que c'est comme au
monopoly à la raison qui vous a marqué
erreur de la banque en votre faveur
c'est très clair du désert du labri gym
et je suis entièrement d'accord il se
serait grandi en plus ans déjà on a fait
une erreur tout ça et gentleman chez
moto je vous le dis je le colle applab
alors on atteint là et si vous voulez
vous bah oui genou droit d'alerté
judith rero qu'est ce tu peux faire je
connais bien aux armées vont se servir
de la loi souvenez vous quand il ya eu
les télés à 30 tours
ils ont dit les gens ne pouvaient pas
ignorer ce à quoi servent un rôti
jacques a tenu golden 80 centimes et moi
je trouve qu'il devrait faire direction
[Musique]
vous quand vous êtes chanter dit
esthéticienne ou si vous aviez arracher
des poils de cul gratuitement mais on
voit bien qu'il ya des gens qui ont
forcément usagers commandes
tu te disais des copains mais ça des
camions entiers et mais ça peut mettre
les gens dans le rouge pour rien pour de
la nourriture donc laisser les oui mais
alors ça c'est alors s'agit là ça c'est
la france de kelly bédouins de la
générosité et bae
non mais elle nous invite tous à mort